[Music]  so it's been about four years I  understand in these your words that  there were times when you had trouble  just keeping going you didn't think he  could go on any further hey yeah I  didn't really want to I know I have this  wonderful family and grandchildren too  and I felt guilty for even feeling like  that but I really honestly would wish  that I didn't have to wake up in the  morning I would never have taken my life  but I really felt that way because when  you wake up you have to realize it's  real and you relive it all over again  people think that you should just get  over it you know that that's that  they've not experienced this so a night  there are people that have in my heart  about all of them it's heartbreak  you